no welcome to this video after some
break after white which really was very
very long tournament and lots of content
that I produced them I'm back with some
stuff here live game 15 minute game on
the ICC and we have got a king's indian
classical variation well black played a
quick Knight to d7 you had a fairly
typical king's indian porn structure
yeah now whiter threatens 92 this is
really a threat because it sets up the
ideal peace configuration and he didn't
attend to this thread so this should be
very comfortable for me now young he
opts for this some be six a five set up
to try to block the Queen side the
problem is that you never really get the
queenside completely blocked so I could
play a three before I want or I could
play on the King side this is the good
thing I've not cast out yet so also
Kings I play as some it's quite
interesting or let's say em it's not
it's this is not the prelude to an
attack but I'm trying to prevent f5 in
the long run a 3 before would also be
fine but I like this way to play the
Kings inion trying to reduce the counter
play two to nothing and now h4 h5 f5 I
can just take two times and opened up
the the G file
so now the G file is opened wide also
has the square u form yeah this is an
interesting moment now 95 one possible
way to play this is to simply capture
this night and then play a night reform
just one way but this a bishop can also
be a useful piece the III bishop
protecting f2 and down trying to to sort
of keep the position together but then
ok this is still tempting getting the
foursquare so um yeah Bishop to d3 I
could play protecting at five yeah let's
start start with this move click in
Chester played this in simple fashion
and now I've got you form a plan now is
Queenie to and long castle at the end
trying to play with the night only four
against the bishop on g7 the only
problem is that I'm not so well
developed this is could be a problem I
need to be a bit cautious for the next
couple of moves that that my piece
coordination is a good enough to to play
this Queen g4 so possibility also
so I would gain one or two moves then
it's no doubt that I would have a really
substantial advantage but it's not so
clear if my coordination is good enough
rucca form could be a problem he text
the age for porn yeah this is a problem
Oh interesting yeah one way to go here
snide g5 it's a very direct move just am
attacking the Sun or try to play a 96
attacking both on the rock and the Queen
but his kin his her on F on c4 he could
take C form but I can play 96 then it's
not not a terrible idea what else I
could play h5 simple move okay come on
let's play h5 I'm spend too much time
you could play Knight f6 now attacking
the night only form ok i would probably
reply Queenie to
yeah the position isn't isn't totally
clear really one idea could be a knight
f6 now Queenie to take stakes and Queen
d7 attending Queen fi for attending rook
evade this Bishop 286 mmm interesting
okay this could be a play just to
prevent long castles of course them I
could play I could play roof g1 check i
could go king 2 h8 and rook g-form try
to get rid of them off the rook at least
maybe I should do that okay this rook is
an annoying piece try to exchange it the
idea now is just take on f4 and play
Queen g-form if he goes rook to be eight
I probably just play be three I know
this position looks updated shaky it
looks a bit shaky so what now yeah
probably I need to take this it takes
with the poor now I can play Queen earth
readers should be okay
take the bishop yeah well probably the
same probably the same tween f3 and then
probably kingi to rugby 8i just play b3
this isn't wasn't a big deal and
interesting about him okay he could
consider to take with the porn queen a
three and then a move like Queen to e8
and interesting yeah and possibly am
Bishop g7 coming at some not a bad bad
idea okay go into a free blood some or
something is there something else now I
probably also need to block the spawn so
f3 is not done not possible at some
point I'd like to Castle long infirm he
allows me to do that Queenie aight i can
just dumb Castle I think cannot take h5
rogue h1 sub problem
Queenie adium and you can take on UFO of
course Knight takes you four Knight
takes e4 in time yeah we should be seven
maybe attacking the beep on I'd love to
get a night to you six then but term
it's not easy yeah like is probably okay
the bishop on g7 is some lack of peace
to play Bishop g7 Andrew p8 attacking
the booty porn and if I can I've castle
long then of course my king is also
under under fire yeah it's not easy to
decide on the best move order here for
black I probably just take me form keep
it simple you also just then taking only
for and Queenie seven is certainly not
bad yeah this it takes a four move was a
good decision this really gives them
ideas on the long diagonal also Queen
e72 to e5 might be a possibility
you
oh yeah yeah Black is fine here Queenie
seven also good we need seven long
castles and TM cut out all this one okay
I need to guess along that son okay I
just I just recognized if I castle long
it takes on e4 mind I take with the
night he's got the move go into a form
and yeah one do I have much choice
probably not if he takes on e4 I will
take with the Queen what about this move
we can play a free check out okay I take
with the night yeah I don't really like
this position I'm going to take with the
night Queen a form i could play queen
bee three after not our Q&A forum not
sure if the check f3s are such a big
deal on 94 and Queenie five for the
month but for put to a play against this
Queenie five chapters really not not so
great iam nadie father's Queenie five
also Queenie five Bishop g7 my damn my
light doesn't really have a good post
this is a problem it doesn't have a
secure square square square summer
Queenie 43 takes h5 I've always look
aged one out of the Sun this is probably
not not a big problem yeah okay let's
let's let's play this I don't really
like it but I don't seem that Quint XD
force any better
yes something went wrong here in the
last couple of moves like certainly has
a fine position yeah this is always
possible first time playing would be aid
yeah the B file and you still got this
Queen a form
hmm when a for some very very annoying
move I cannot play something like b3
this would be suicidal on the long
diagonal
yeah how do I defend against this not at
all easy
you
and
yeah maybe I should turn try something
like this on Queen a four-player oopsie
one group c 1 Roxy to and just try to
defend all this so not very enterprising
but what can you do if I would get a
couple of moves like rook c 1 c 2 23 f 3
i would down would start to make a bit
of sense again but like I certainly fine
also I just I just saw that he plays
Bishop g7 roped it to Queenie five how
do I am how do I cover all this yeah
this is probably very good for black
yeah of course he finds all those moves
rookie 225 how do I cover be tuned and
also i forgot this night hain probably i
need to play something like this it's
not great but maybe maybe i can get the
night to 12 b 5 later at least them
blocking the B file he goes 25 now which
I will detect the night yeah probably i
need to play rocket III right on i'll
move the king again keen to see two very
ugly move while rock d3 isn't exactly
great either
maybe maybe Kim c2 after all yeah candy
to get going here route before maybe
just be three it is ugly
you
before b3 is really really ugly do I
have some something else 23 yeah maybe
23 idea being a 3 rook somewhere be 8 or
something and then not be 50 no be to
saying but this could be an idea if you
would take the poor now yeah probably
you can just take the porn I mean it's
not I don't have anything great after
that
okay let's push this rope back and then
play 95 of course on 9 i'd be 53 my dad
just play 25 again
hmm yeah it's not much fun yo okay so
what what can I do yeah when you're five
I was some think I know I could move
like Quincy three but this of course is
very stupid move ok
yeah one at ya it's always amazing
sometimes at done he's not covering c7
or something just playing probably just
playing the best most active moves
Queenie to the idea okay but i am mr. 1m
i must take its no don't have fun a big
choice can't I need to get to get the
pawn out of the long diagonal I still
have some chances because I've got this
three against two and okay i can take
first and then play 96 I've got red a
majority a two against one now which
might net me some some some some ass
porn and now I'm threatening rook p8
mate I could have checked also and then
play 96 check and take here this would
have been interesting
what okay this was a bit of a sudden
sudden end of this game he played really
really well just one really bad slip
with Bishop e3 I think I'm probably okay
now oh the computer actually gives wide
the big advantage after taking and King
e4 yeah I'm very active I'm I was pretty
sure that I'm okay now but this was of
course quite quite amazing yeah here I'm
just outplayed I mean maybe really
outplayed me I can I can only play
passive defense here but maybe this
wasn't so so great after all right now
definitely a Scott play he's got an
extra porn of course but it's just at
the moment the h7 pawn and of course
this is a passed pawn and potentially
dangerous but it's not doing so much at
the moment and I'm quick here with my
pawns and my activity the King now on d3
is an asset can can be used as an
attacking piece like this is probably
all right on already but I simply I'm i
really miss played played this this
position is opening
yeah I'm a coordination wasn't wasn't
good enough for this this kind of play
he am a queen geforce an alternative
many the idea being that i can flick
this in something like this it's
probably better yeah yeah well
interesting game a really played a
deeply really played a good game only at
the ante he overlooked and made in one
other than that he played really fine
yeah thanks for watching an interesting
game nevertheless and i'll be back soon